how to meet an angel investor so I got a
great question from one of my readers on
ceremony one of my viewers on YouTube
love you guys
Christine who wrote in the say hi Evan
I'd like to know how to meet an angel
investor I'm just about ready to get
things moving but we'll need help
financially Thanks this is a great
question and I know a lot of
entrepreneurs are trying to get money to
launch a business angel investors could
be a good way to go how do you find one
so I have an entire Zuka guide on this
how to find the angel how to pitch them
everything that they look for while
they're gonna you know crunch down your
deal how to maximize your chances of
success with them so you can check that
out if you're really considering going
down this path I'd highly encourage you
you look at that zuga guide we have but
how to meet an angel to answer the
question the first thing you have to
understand is most angels they're not
too vocal about their angel investing
okay most angels all set don't go around
and say hey I'm an angel investor
because they're gonna get bombarded with
pitches right most of them don't have
websites there's no directory because
they don't want to get hit with too many
pitches for their companies so they work
through informal networks they work
through their friends the main reason is
a lot of these guys they're not
professional angel investors they're
part-time there's a term in the industry
called DDI
which is doctors or dentists with
disposable income so that's your first
group a lot of the angel investors are
just wealthy professionals they have a
full time job and they're looking to
make investments in the companies as
something to do on the side so doctors
and dentists are a great starting point
my dentist likes to tell me that he
doesn't have a lot of excitement in his
life he's got the same job coming in day
in day out and he likes to live
vicariously through his investments so
that's his chance to show off to his
friends and to have a little bit of
excitement because he doesn't get much
of it in his own life so it's something
that you can look at start talking your
dentists or talking to your doctor even
if they want to invest they probably
know other people who might so that's
your first group
the second way is look for professionals
who can connect you so a lot of the
angel deals are sourced through
accountants through lawyers because they
are connected to the angel investors
right financial advisors is another
group so if you let these people know
what you're up to right who's your
financial adviser who is your lawyer who
is your accountant or find people in
your network who are any of those
positions and let them know what you're
looking for because chances are they
have a client who is an angel investor
now they have to believe in what you're
doing you have to think is a good fit
for the client they're not just going to
introduce you to their client because
it's got to make everybody look good
right but it is a value-add service
right if if your lawyer is bringing you
deals then you like that lawyer a lot
more so they'll be happy to introduce
you and it helps them look good but your
deal has to make sense for them so start
talking to lawyers and accountants and
financial advisors and think about who
is in your network who might have that
position because they could be great
facilitators for you those are going to
be your two best sources your DDIs
doctors and debts is a disposable income
and then your connectors financial
planners financial advisors accountants
lawyers a third smaller group are going
to be angel groups and this is what a
lot of people try to get into but it's
not where most of the deals happen and
this is where angel investors they form
a group in a city and there may be
twenty of them are 40 of them or
whatever it is and they have pitch
nights where entrepreneurs come in and
they make their pitch and the investors
see is is right for me or not and they
make a decision and usually those are
done on a regular basis I might be a
quarterly pitch night over dinner or
whatever it is you come in pitch you get
to meet the teams of angels and
hopefully you line the deal out of that
but there are too many angel groups and
those events don't happen too often and
so that's all you're relying on as your
strategy it's gonna be really hard to
get that going so you're gonna have a
lot better luck with your dede eyes and
your connectors one last option that you
might want to look at is
crowd sourcing so look at websites like
Kickstarter com where you're not even
giving up equity in your business but
you're giving your basically pre-selling
whatever product or service you have and
it's a great way to raise startup
capital without giving up any any part
of your company but still also create
tons of awareness in in your business
one last thought about angel since we're
on the topic because this this is really
important don't just take money for
money okay you want somebody who can
offer real value to your business you're
looking for a strategic partner so you
know if you're bringing on that dentist
make sure he or she has a passion for
your business I might be able to make
some connections in to helping your
company and is not just giving money
because if they don't understand your
business and they don't have a passion
for hey they can't offer you any help
but B if something gets hard they're
gonna start giving you a hard time right
they want to see a return and if they
don't understand your business and
they're not helping out they're gonna
give you a lot more pressure so try to
get somebody who's smart money who can
be a partner for you and not just give
you dollars belief that's my advice I
have a lot more to say in the topic but
that's answering the question and I know
we have a little bit of time so let me
know what you think leave a comment
below if you've gone for angel investing
if you're going for it now if you have
questions leave it below like a video
response and you guys like this video
thumbs up below click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon